face à gilles question numéro un
réverbère oui chantal est ce que votre
conjoint ou jointe alors oui au sénégal
sans vous
[Rires]
de la première question le jeu est
fière de paniers oui oui elle ne termine
pas non non on a des relais question pas
même s'ils posent la deuxième question
tu vas
va-t-elle le sanitaire avec son
téléphone
oui et c'est ainsi sédières va-t-elle
aux solitaires plus de une heure avec
son téléphone
parfois at elle des problèmes gastriques
je ne pense pas voilà l'appel les a fait
tomber dans les toilettes non moins huit
questions 3 lewis surprise enfin d'avoir
une conversation
oui oui oui ils communiquent ensemble à
bien question numéro 4 mais tel six ans
pour préparer un mariage
oui je ne peux pas le nier non plus et
vous avez beaucoup travaillé
vous at elle déjà proposé un plan trop
mais sans vous
[Applaudissements]
non non non question numéro six au lit
il était mutée déjà arrivé de crier un
prénom qui commence par ces grecs et qui
finit par aérienne
la sentence est tombée
elle aurait pu créer votre prêt moi non
oui beaucoup elle aurait
bien des limites cessionnaire attendu la
vérité quand vous êtes un ami chinois
mais franchement jamais les amis elle
aurait pu créer son prénom non mais
alors est pas dans une posture sexuelle
mais par par goût par amitié et l'amour
platonique l'amour platonique voilà
assez platani qu'eric
1,8 ya le plateau et moitié
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
là